the country is a lot less free than it
used to be but some states are trying
hard to remain
american the biggest of them is florida
florida's leaders have managed to
protect for the most part
their constituents constitutional rights
even during the pandemic or in a lot of
places those rights were cancelled
florida did not go into a total lockdown
many businesses and beaches stayed open
so what was the result of this well
according to our public policy expert
anthony
anthony fauci florida should be leading
the country in coronavirus deaths but
that's not true it's not even close
florida has performed far better than
states that shut down completely and
forced people to isolate states like new
york and new jersey
last summer at the height of the
pandemic new york and new jersey had
five times the number of coronavirus
deaths
on a per capita basis and far more
people live in florida than in
new york or new jersey new york still
has more corona cases per day than
florida does
today we've learned it's even worse than
we thought in the northeast it turns out
that
new york's governor andrew cuomo sent
more than 9 000
coronavirus patients from hospitals to
nursing homes
in the early days of the pandemic those
numbers are almost twice as high as what
we thought
twice as high as what officials had
reported in new york according to the
new york post the top cuomo aide has
admitted
this was a cover-up it was lying putting
out the real numbers he worried would be
quote
used against us by federal prosecutors
and donald trump we'll have more on that
remarkable story tomorrow
all of this is uncomfortable for our
media to talk about for obvious reasons
and not just because cnn
literally employs the brother of the
governor of new york on tv
and it's not simply because florida is
run by republicans for the most part
the key point is that florida proves
that people don't need to
give up their rights as americans just
because
some bureaucrat demands they do just
because some career politician
wants more power now at msnbc which
exists to protect career politicians
there's only one solution to this
problem
florida's leadership needs to be
punished immediately
republican governor ron desantis cares
more about keeping the state open for
business
than about keeping people alive how do
you roll out a national
plan when you have to go through
governors like him
is there a way that the administration
can get around people like ron desantis
really quickly though what do you do
with dumb governors i'm sorry to put it
this way but you have governors like ron
desantis who don't care about
kovid what do you do with recalcitrant
governors republican governors so eager
to claw their way to the top of the
trumpian food chain
they've happily picked up his war
against science
and his lack of respect or reverence for
life itself
the defenders of democracy there is
there a way we can get around people
like ron desantis
people meaning elected officials voted
in statewide
in other words how can the federal
government shut down the state of
florida and overthrow its governor
well the bite administration is
considering its options actually
they've come up apparently with a plan
to punish florida and its governor
according to the miami herald and we're
quoting the biden administration is
considering whether to impose domestic
travel restrictions including on florida
anonymous white house source explained
exactly what's going on here this is a
quote for the ages listen
quote this is a war and we're at battle
with the virus war
is messy and unpredictable and all
options are on the table
what all options are on the table this
is war
who are you talking about you're talking
about american citizens
a rare moment of honesty from an
anonymous white house official no
administration has ever suggested doing
anything like this
the white house is singling out specific
states for punishment
today ron desantis made it clear that he
knows what is going on here and will
resist it
i think it would be unconstitutional it
would be unwise and it would be unjust
and if you think about it restricting
the right of our country
while allowing illegal aliens to pour
across the southern border unmolested
would be a ridiculous but very damaging
farce so we will oppose it 100 percent
it would not be based in science it
would purely be a political attack
against the people of florida
so the pretext for shutting off florida
from the rest of the country is that
there's a
mutation of the coronavirus spreading in
the state
okay that mutation is also spreading in
california the biggest democratic state
and yet no one in the white house is
talking about destroying california or
its governor gavin newsom instead
they're defending gavin newsom from a
democratic recall effort against voters
so democrats know exactly what this is
it's punishment
for the largest republican state last
march when the white house
floated a broader lockdown that would
affect the northeast the governor of new
york was apoplectic he called it quote a
federal declaration of war
a lockdown is what they did in wuhan
china declared the brother of cnn's
anchor
we are not in china and we're not in
wuhan i believe it would be illegal
he's actually probably right but
democrats have changed their view
they have decided we are going to punish
this state to which
all the taxpayers in our big failed ugly
gray dirty crime-ridden states are
fleeing
these people are the most effective real
estate salesman the state of florida has
ever seen and they're punishing florida
for it marco rubio represents the state
of florida in the united states senate
he joins us now senator i have to say
this seems given what's going on in
california i don't understand the
scientific basis for a suggestion like
this
it seems very obviously political
punishment how does it strike you
it's actually quite ironic the day after
donald trump imposed the china travel
ban
that joe biden accused him of xenophobia
then in march he tweeted out that
travel bans any war against anywhere in
the world do not work
but now he wants to impose them on
american citizens you know tonight if
you arrive at the u.s southern border
with a child
you will be allowed entry to the country
you will be allowed to stay here pending
an asylum trial that you may are hearing
that you may never show up for
but if you're now an american citizen
living in florida that wants to travel
they're going to put some form of
restriction in your way
i mean it's clearly unconstitutional but
we should also pass a law here making
clear that this is not within the power
of an administration to do
that you can't just you know stand in
the way of the ability of americans to
travel freely in their country for
something that by the way is not
supported by the science
it it seems like a a pretty radical
thing to say
be the kind of thing you might say if
you wanted to stoke real conflict making
people
people really paranoid make them feel
like they're really under attack
shutting off states from the rest of the
country
what i mean why would they even float an
idea because i think they're trying to
punish florida i think they're
embarrassed by what florida's done
florida's embarrassed california
florida's in paris new york it hosted a
super bowl with actual people
in the stands you know the predictions
about florida didn't come true
and they're like we can't let this stand
we've got to come up with something i
honestly think there's an element of
that that involves punishment i really
do
so i mean if you look at the state of
new york i
you know we're not going to get the
numbers for probably another year but it
looks to me very much checking the real
estate numbers
like they're losing their tax base at
very high speed for florida
they must resent that well not just from
that we've never had people move from
to florida from california they're
coming from california but look at the
airlines the airlines have rerouted a
bunch of flights
to florida to all kinds of communities
people are telling you what they think
about what's going on in these states
and it's not just a pandemic by the way
it's
streets that are not livable anymore
garbage that isn't being picked up
that's right anarchy in the streets it's
more than just a pandemic the pandemic
is terrible but it is added to all these
other schools that aren't open i mean
there's kids in california haven't gone
to school i read these tweets about a
lot of these kids that were
high school football prospects who've
lost their whole senior year i mean
they're just stuck
all wiped out and on top of that they
had a terrible record on covert
so if you mismanage a state so
completely that everyone with a job
flees should you
but should you be allowed to force the
rest of the country to bail you out
that's what they're going to try and do
yeah and again it's it's that's that's
those are pre-existing debts
we should not be in the business of
saying well we're already in trouble to
begin with this is a good opportunity to
get you a bunch of money so
you can help fund all the mismanagement
all the terrible union contracts you
have all the mess you've made of your
cities or your state
that's exactly what they're looking for
this is not about helping a city that
needs help that's one thing
this is who's let me say their tax base
was wiped out by the pandemic
this is about pre-existing debt in the
billions of dollars
pension plans that are bankrupting
states and and cities and and counties
across the country
and now they view the pandemic as the
latest opportunity to get bailed out
yeah unlike pretty much everyone else in
florida you're from the state of florida
so congratulations on that
you were in early senator rubio great to
see you thank you
thank you